those who have created their account on
the portal please let me know by uh
typing in a one or yes in the chat box
and others can just click on the link of
the portal and create an account for
yourself or sign up using your existing
google accounts
let me do that for you
if you just click on the login button
you will be redirected to a sign up page
here you can either create an account
for yourself that is simply put in your
mail id and create a password for
yourself or use any of your google
accounts to sign up on the portal
please let me know in the chat box once
you have completed your sign up or you
if you have already uh signed up on the
portal
so minus many for a person with a
background of
chemistry if you are interested in
biochemistry then definitely it's
computer-aided drug designing or drug
repurposing that you can
proceed further with and we will be
having a session on structural biology
computational biology first the
structural aspect of biology
specifically so uh there i think you
might find your research interest and
you can work on it right dr mohit
would you like to give a suggestion to
manasvini on that
okay now i would be ending the pool
thank you
everyone for answering the questions in
the poll
now if you have completed your sign up
let me just show you quickly how you can
update your profile and why is it
important to have an updated profile on
the portal so if you click on your mail
address on the uh menu bar that you can
see on the portal on the top you will be
redirected to a profile section it's
very important that you have an updated
profile because this is the way we get
to know about your progress we wonder
your progress at the back end and we do
feature the best profiles with the best
progress and scores on our social media
platforms and therefore it's important
to have an updated profile picture
please make sure that your name is in
title case and you have linked your
social media accounts and also add a
brief file about yourself it could be
about your educational background and
your research and trust
and also when you will be a part of the
workshop then you will get the starter
subscription active for a month where
you will get the access to all the
courses on the omixlogic portal that you
can learn from
now if i take you through the portal and
uh guide you how you can navigate
through the portal so you just need to
click on the courses uh tab on the menu
and you will be redirected to a list of
courses that you can see here
on the right side you you will see
various tags which mentions multi-omics
fields and data science
now let's see you just want to see what
our courses are present that you can
learn from so just click on course and
every course will be
displayed in the menu
and you can simply pick the course that
you would like to learn from
also if you would like to
go through any of the project examples
then all you need to do is just click on
the projects and you will get a list of
example projects where you will learn
how the methodologies and the concepts
that you will learn in the course could
be applied to answer in real life
uh i request all the participants to
please mute themselves and if you have
any question please put in the chat box
for me to answer
thank you
okay so now talking about the workshop
registration
so if you just click on the programs uh
tab on the menu on the portal you will
be redirected to list of programs here
you need to just simply type workshop
and you will be redirected to the page
of workshop on computational biology and
biomedical data science
on this program page when you scroll
down you will find
the schedule first of all and the
schedule is listed for the 27th and 28th
of the workshop we will be soon listing
out the premise life sciences schedule
as well
on the program page you will find three
different levels that you can pick and
enroll for the workshop
the first level is the business level
that is for dollar fifteen intermediate
level is for dollar thirty and advanced
is for dollar forty five now what is the
difference between these three different
levels
in the first level definitely you will
get the access to all the resources on
the loan on massage portal
in the intermediate level
uh you will get the access to one-on-one
mentor support that is
missing from the business level where
you will be getting the assistance only
in group meetings but in case of
intermediate you will get the one-on-one
mentor support as well and in the uh
advanced license you will get some extra
time to work on any of the projects that
you may propose uh in
during the duration of your working on
any of the courses on the portal right
so that is the difference between these
three different levels many are times
participants get confused which level
should they pick up so if you want to
work on a
short project
for
submitting in your institute as a report
or just for your experience to get some
hands-on then an advanced license will
be the best for you if you are looking
for some one-on-one mentor guidance then
an intermediate level will be the best
one for you or else the beginner level
is always there that you can opt for
and once you uh pick any of these
subscription
types you will get the access to all the
courses on the on the logic portal just
the difference would be in the duration
of the time period that you will be
getting the access to
so that was a very simple process to get
yourself registered